[Musique]
était-il en train de cuisiner un peu mon 1 1 était égal
Curtis sur le même qu'il aura des
moments difficiles numériquement
[Musique]
nous avons constaté qu'il se transmettait des
moustiques mères à leur progéniture,
donc une fois que la population de moustiques est
infectée, la prochaine génération de moustiques
arrive  à travers - tous graves
[Musique]
et développé des outils pour le contrôler
et il y a certainement eu des
avancées majeures et une diminution de la
quantité de paludisme au cours des
deux dernières décennies, mais nous n'avons
rien eu de vraiment nouveau et révolutionnaire au cours
des dernières  quelques années et je pense
que cela va être vraiment essentiel
parce que beaucoup des outils que nous avons
deviennent un peu moins efficaces à mesure que les
moustiques développent une résistance à beaucoup de
produits chimiques que nous utilisons
[Musique]